Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from people
in the audience. My favorite people. We take
calls on the Friday show via Discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Once you're there,
you go to the waiting lobby and you raise your
hand, you click, raise hand that way. I know you
want to talk to me. And it's a very, very exciting
thing. Let's go first. This is just first. This
isn't this isn't the be all, end all. We're
going to go first to tie in Iowa and see what
is on Ty's mind. Ty, welcome to the program.
What's going on? What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
Speaker 1: Hey.
Speaker 2: Everyone doing well? Okay, that's good.
All right, So I just wanted to ask so you know how
there was the riots in Brazil recently, right?
Speaker 1: Of course.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So how how how much do you think
those were? Probably inspired by January 69.
Speaker 1: Well, I think it was it's not only
the model from January 6th, but Bannon and
Jason Miller and others affiliated with Trump
were advising Jair Bolsonaro in November about,
quote, next steps. It's like next steps,
dude, you lost. So it's quite literally the
same model the Q went on. People seem to have
potentially been involved, at least online,
in fomenting what went on. It's quite literally a
copycat thing. And this was exactly the concern.
Speaker 2: And yeah, I do things that I don't feel
like there's going to be a whole like hearing or
I don't know, I can't really see that happening
because I think like he seems like he's been a
lot more silent than Trump has, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, he ended up in the
hospital. He was he was in but Bolsonaro was
in Florida at the time. And he went to a KFC,
he went to a Publix, and then he ended up
in the hospital with abdominal pain. I mean,
it's a dramatically different situation. Also,
they did start arresting a bunch of people pretty
damn quickly down in Brazil. Doesn't mean that
it was perfectly handled, but it doesn't seem
as though it's all going to go the same way.
Speaker 2: Yeah. You know what's crazy is, like,
there are actually even more people are somewhat
I think the capital of January six is like 3000
and like at Brazil was like 4000, but like the
area was vacant, so it was a lot less violent.
Speaker 1: I don't have those numbers in front
of me, but that that is interesting. I will I
will look into that.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, Ty. Well,
thank you very much. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: All right. That's my dog
barking. All right, You might want to.
Speaker 1: All right. Say hi to your dog for me.
There is Ty from Iowa with some
very, very powerful declarations.